I would also like to welcome you to the
theodor w adorno
the great charismatic
intellectual in the history of
philosophy adorno was
undoubtedly our
most brilliant dialectician together with
hegel dialectics tells you everything
thesis antithesis synthesis adorno could see things from two sides like no other, i.e. think in terms of thesis
and
antithesis  in position and
negation in opinion and counter-opinion
he even managed to say something in many of
his formulations within a
single sentence and the
opposite of that i brought him
a little taster
philosophy is that all the most serious but
then again it's not that serious
adorno you will hear a number of
such things from adorno he was
already a legend during his lifetime, from
1959 to 1969 he
gave most of the lectures and interviews on
radio and television in the young
federal republic in post-war germany
and was the great
left-wing intellectual after the second
w  eltkrieg comparable only to john
kohlsaat in france and by the way like
sattler he not only inspired the youth
and all left-wing intellectual
forces but he was actually
very short of
stature a bit stocky he has big horn-rimmed glasses a bald head and
like pulsare he also had a few
affairs with  young pretty women and
today it's all about his
core idea his lectures were
always overcrowded people came from
all over the world to hear adorno live for once in their
lives but
ladies and gentlemen many left the
lecture and then
didn't have anything by far  understood everything
adorno was able to increase and become so abstract in his cell
and has always been
so
abstract that hardly anyone
could understand or has understood that we then really well
and his main work
the negative dialectics is
really strong stuff as well as
philosophically trained a whole
thick chunk  and it's worth it but it's
worth it in any case and the
philosopher odo marquard once said
you have to have had adorno like the
measles
and i'm trying to infect you with these posts today
and so we're right in the middle of it as
adorno and horkheimer from exile  in
america country during the war you had to
migrate came back to the
destroyed post-war
germany you already had this book in your luggage
the famous dialectics of enlightenment
which became the standard work of critical
theory this
book hit
like a bomb after a while because it was the first time  a
critique of criticism the dialectic of
enlightenment you know the enlightenment
itself was actually the great epoch
of criticism the enlighteners
russo montesquieu dieter rodi
you can lure encyclopedists yourself you can be genuinely totally
critical they have criticized feudalism
the divine right
monarchy religion superstition
that is  they were very kr  ithically they wanted
the enlightenment, the
French say illumination,
the bright enlightenment, the light of
reason should go everywhere and
enlighten everything, and
the English spoke of
introductory, so that was the big
idea of the edition, they wanted to free
eople from their immat
rity  and now adorno and horkheimer come along
and say the opposite was
the case the dialectic of enlightenment
looks like this mankind should be
liberated by reason and in the
end it turns into its opposite it
is true that adorno says that we
are
to the fullest these days
who enjoy the world in an enlightened way insofar
as we naturally enjoy insane advantages with advances
in technology in medicine in
healthcare in the transport
routes in mobility
we take the subway we will
watch we will go to the cinema we
have all the options the shelves in the
supermarket make sense  but we
pay a lot for it  very high price we
have so agrana distanced ourselves further and further
from outer nature and from
our inner nature to the point that we have
even lost our ability to love
every person today without any
exception feels loved too little
because everyone can love too little
that is because  in capitalism everything has
its
price nothing is done for free anymore we
sell our workforce for a
certain amount of money and
because every service has to be paid for we lose
our natural feeling
for sympathy for the fate of others
if it is not paid for and this
total reification is just that
then, with great consequences, there is also the fact that in
capitalism there is also a kind of
artificial need to get around
that artificial needs are
created and there is even a
certain product fetishism, for example that
the car is no
longer just a means of transport for many people,
but a guide  your id  entity from this
dead object from the vehicle
were huge sports cars i
have only just seen a middle class couple again they got out of a tank like this
from the
suv with giants in and stuff and then they
have some bag of organic apples in there
biomarkt fetched it's amazing
what's happening
at the moment and it's still up to date you
'll see many of madonna's theses are red hot
what's more, in mass
art and consumer society we're also
losing our individuality because
we're all in the same way
sell us continue in the same way being
supplied by the consumer goods industry, so to speak, also with regard to our leisure time
we lose our
individuality i will explain that later but
first a quote he says for
many people it is already an
impertinence if they say i as
far as it goes  his suspicion that we all
here in the s  we
have lost our individuality and
he now says we are as it were going up in
a world of illusion and there is not the
individual the problem not the
reification not the loss of the
ability to love not the true is
finished does not have to be consumption he says is
entire our entire form of existence is
now  spoiled by the capitalist mode of
production
that's why he can say the
whole thing is untrue that is
also directed against hegel, where he
would say, as is well known, that was is the whole thing
and we increase in evolution
until we come to the truth no he says
you to it  is vice versa we live in
a context that is objectively delusional as he says quote
we are
completely
manipulated and
you may know this theory that
we live in an illusory world we
believe too early when we go to
work and go out we are in
the real world we live positive things
negative but in reality
we actually move in a  ner illusory world
this radical thesis was
formulated in the first year by a very old philosopher
that we only live in
the shadows that you all know of course clearly
plato in his allegory of the cave has
already told us that people sit
tied up in the cave most
people are the kind in which  world that
you sit tied up in a cave
look at the shell wall and
only see the shadows there and hear the
echoes and believe but that would be the
real world in which you
hope for a lifetime one can then
free himself goes upstairs and then sees
the real world is coming back and telling
people you are in a world of illusion you
have to and that is also the idea of
that he says we have to get out of the world of illus
on we have to educate the soul highe
and open our eyes to the t
uth for the true world  for those
for the good true and beautiful is much
more radical adorno's more radical adorno says
now we can't do that anymore we
're already a lot  too long in the cave
we can't get out easily anymore
we are so caught up in this
capitalist gear that we
no longer even recognize where the real
world could be no location outside
of the gear can be referred to anymore
from which the spook by name  it
would be impossible to name a location outside of
the gearbox can no longer be referred to from which we can call the whole spook by its
name there is no
longer any outside perspective that's the big
problem you said i can just get out of the cave
and say we're in the
cave  are in an object this
delusion connection and then comes his very famous quote
that you all probably know
today more censored today more and more
quotes than before there is no
right life in the wrong one so even
if we notice and have the feeling
actually we are unhappy in
our current life of we ca
n't move individual adjusting screws
because there are k  a true
life in the wrong
and with this general suspicion against
capitalism that it is overshaping our whole way of
life
and continues to shape and
ideologize it and we no longer even
know what true life actually
means, he justifies it in ever new
critical attempts and so he became the
main representative of critical
theory critical theory is also called the
frankfurt school because it was
a certain
way of thinking critical of capitalism that started after the war
marc heimann belonged to it too
, max horkheimer or the
famous psychoanalyst erich fromm
or marcuse and a few more and
all of them  these thinkers have made it their task to analyze and criticize
the effects of
our production methods on our
humanity,
they were all marxists and
have also called themselves marxists
, but and now we are getting
there, by the way, they were in frankfurt at the
institute for soz  That's why
they're also called the Frankfurt School because
they were all in Frankfurt and
now we'll get to
why it's called critical theory and
that's how it's called critical
theory because
you said Marx was
wrong that at some point there would automatically
be a classless society
because you have to remember one
thing was no maradona saw what's going on in
russia they
experienced stalinism after the war they
knew that's not the real
existing socialism is not a
goal to strive for they saw
what's going on everywhere in germany france
that the workers  also
succumbed to consumption and no
longer had any awareness of being revolutionary at all,
so they gave up the idea that
there would still be a revolution
and critical theory now says
we only have to criticize the existing
situation and go into negation
we can't say  en where
the ultimate goal of the story is critical
theory is negation of the negation which
does not transition into position
so one does not criticize from a
state of classless
society what is all wrong in capitalism
but criticizes solely from the
present situation and
when society changes
just the new situation again that's
critical theory yes well
the main work of this critical theory
that's what adorno wrote together with
horkheimer i've already mentioned it briefly
and right at the beginning comes
the central thesis that the first sentence of
this dialectic of enlightenment that's
what it has always said  has enlightenment in the
broader sense of progressing
thinking pursued the goal of taking away people's fear and appointing
them
as masters but the fully
enlightened the earth shines in the sign of
triumphant calamity so the
dialectical thought is already there the
enlightenment has always tried yes
in mind  e progressive
thinking to take away people's fear yes and to use them
as lords over nature
but after that has succeeded and we are
no longer afraid the
earth shines in the sign of triumphant misfortune what
does he mean by that
quite simply it small example times
centuries i could even  say
thousands of people were afraid
of nature and damp well the plague was
the devil or a punishment from god a
thunderstorm the harvest was hailed so
they starved they also sacrificed out of this fear to
the god of
thunder or they held harvest festivals
if only he  the sky turned
black the thunderstorms
lit candles and so to speak the
metaphysical forces agree that
they will not be punished nowadays
the hail flyer rises and shoots
a bit of chemistry ii wanted to understand
you we are enlightened we
no longer believe in the god of thunder etc and
still something happens  crucial
the earth shines  in the sign of triumph
obtained misfortune today the
enlightenment has
prevailed rationalism reason everything is supported by
reason and enlightened
superstition is gone faith is gone we
control nature like never before
we are now what the
enlightenment wanted they wanted us as
masters  we are the masters
we no longer have to go hunting
and make a sacrifice to the hunting gods beforehand
, we have
factory farms we simply go to the
supermarket its huge meat counters
there is beef there is
pork there are we
control everything we are  the
absolute lords of nature also in
agriculture yes, if there is just not
enough there then bündner there comes the comedian
and which substances we still put in we use
pesticides fungicides we have huge
harvesting machines we are the lords of
nature yes we are no longer afraid  in front of
her and now
something crucial is coming i ziti  ere
people pay for the increase in
their power with the alienation from
what they exercise power over
clearly because we are becoming more and more alienated
from the animals from nature from the
plants from everything that
happens out there we are further and further away
we see the products  often only
in the supermarket and with that we pay for
this exercise of power and not only now
with regard to nature but also
the inner nature the modern
enlightened rational states are
highly organized administered republics
where a gigantic apparatus of officials with
laws covers every single individual
we are from birth  recorded and administered with the
birth certificate until death with the
death certificate
is not just the tax we
are administered for life and says
the dollar is also somewhat undefeated
in a new bondage and
therefore he can say the enlightenment
relates to things like that
dictator to the people he knows them
insofar as  she can manipulate the
man of science knows the things in
sofia she can do there is now
a very crucial sentence so the
enlightenment has started to
sweep away all superstition
and basically only write what we can
really know in the
encyclopedia  the developers
have written a huge
lexicon where really only the knowledge
should be in no I don't think any
superstition only what you can know for sure
and very soon that was also
defined immanuel kant also
defined what really know
is what we do with the  perception can
also see not only what we
classify with the categories but what we can see
with the real perception
and can repeat in the experiment that
is real knowledge and so
this knowledge was
assigned to natural science more and more and the problem
is now the danube says that this
knowledge is not an end in itself but it
serves to  manipulating the world there
is hardly any research
direction
that is paid for by industry or the state probably only research is done
to expand knowledge that should
always serve some purpose they also
make sense when the plague was discovered the bacteria
always knew that there was no
punishment  the devil or god is but
these are bacteria etc. has
developed medicines but says johanna it
also works in such a way that basically every
scientific knowledge is
tried to be used in the
feasibility is purely transferred and
then he brings the bad example of
darwin charles darwin has
scientifically, in the sense of enlightenment,
enlightened the people and said you
are not descendants and creatures of
god descended from adam and eve,
but it is a long evolutionary
process with mutation and selection where
one emerges from the other and in
the end the human being of today is
that  didn't go long and then
an englend  he named herbert spencer
said yes and this
scientific knowledge of the
survival of the fittest also applies and
that was all things the survival of the
hardt also applies between species it
is a single struggle for life
so it is logical that
different species have different races
and different nations  have
always fought and will
continue to fight each other throughout history, by the way, it was
still 50 years before hitler and then in 1933
when the king seized power less than
two years later there were doctors everywhere at
german universities who set
the tone
and there were chairs everywhere for
just a second there were biologists there were doctors
neurophysiologists and
they measured thousands of heads, examined the
physiognomy, the facial features,
natural science tried
to recognize the races and then the
great hypothesis would be put forward by the
doctors that the aryan race is
actually probably the better one
and against  al  le
others can and will prevail they understand
and then erdogan said what happened there
is the enlightenment that has started to dispel
the superstition the myth the
mythology suddenly
turned into a new myth because
that's not true he says it's de
facto not true and  that's why there is a great
danger that modern science, which
started as a result of the enlightenment, will
also turn back into mythology.
that's why he can say that
enlightenment is so entangled with every step it takes that it gets
deeper into mythology
and
it didn't get any better after the second world war
then we noticed that this
scientific hypothesis
that the aryan race would prevail we
that that nonsense was actually very
dangerous
and then by the way the
chairs for ra second were abolished
today as the first biological
chairs are set up interestingly
yes and then says but then it
went on with  then capitalism
it started that was scientifically
proven and i
learned it myself in school that capitalism is more or
less
natural because it is in the nature of man
that he wants to develop himself
egotistically and there is also a scientific book by the way,
the
egotistical  gen yes well we find so
predestined in a competitive
struggle is by the way also interesting in the
past what the struggle of the hard and
today's sociologists there is the
struggle but
you can see he says that's just a
new ideology that's your same
blindness context just
formulated differently  and today's
individual is in there yes and i learned it that way
at school the
secret of the good life yes it has
to live it consists of this magic
triangle they will also say canon
prosperity democracy free
market economy that's how we learned it
yes and  if that is considered to be natural,
it is still today in the
sozialk  unde-lesson then it can
happen that you get completely caught up in this
blinded context
i know the individual has
to be subordinate to the market and he says
the modern individual emerges whose greatest
achievement in the meantime is the
ability to adapt it has to
deny itself and it has to have drives
suppressed you know  yes
nowadays he is very up to date
everyone is talking about residency that is also so
we know that we are better able to
withstand stress it is always the
individual who has to endure and
suppress drives and here he brings
together with horkheimer this famous
example of and  this that makes up
quite a part in the dialectic of
enlightenment because he says he and it is
a symbol of it for modern
people, let me quote you,
he says and that proves to be the archetype
of the bourgeois individual
why this one in particular is very simple
he was forbidden as a legendary figure was the
first who no longer  like the other
ancient heroes
with courage and with a guest is cool again
or like achilles tried
to reach his goal no it was the first
enlightened rational cunning guy
who was funny who used
his reason completely rationally against
superstition and myth that was  the first
cunning and i'll show you here
says the cunning loner is
already homo economics kiss him all the
same reasonable ones and that's why and
there brings up this myth of
polyphemus you may still know him
this holy giant and this it works
with his team unsuspectingly into
the cave then interestingly enough he talks to
polyphemus and asks
for hospitality and the giant asks
who we really are and then he
says clever how he is he is nobody
in ancient greek this is also a play on
words which sounds similar to
odysseus and in which he pretends to be nobody
, he later saves himself and the
crew  life because the the
giant doesn't give you the right to be a guest the cloud stone in
front of the doors is open one after
the other and then decides and
this with the team that you
count and fight then cut this
green tree come out of the fire in
the eye in the night  there is the giant
asleep and then the cry jumps
inside outside is blind and tested
the other giant nobody put out my
eye nobody wants to
fly now nobody catches him and kills him
and the other giants thought he was
crazy yes if
nobody did anything yes  and since
that was the self-
denial of odysseus and what happens then thousands of jobs
every day
say self-denial the second is the
suppression of impulses there brings the
example where the turnover with the crew
in the series n drives by
and
this song of these women has all
succumbed and ships are already there
gone down he pours the whole
team grow so that the gar n  can't
hear list tie yourself to the
poles so he can hear it
and says you mustn't free yourself
even if you then complain so much that
you should go there and then he drives
through it and then the man from Bonn says this
instinctual suppression self-restraint self
-chastisement and the two
the modern employee needs qualities and
that's why this cunning
loner is already the poor homo oeconomicus for
whom all reasonable people are equal
that's a nice part here in the
dialectic of enlightenment then here comes
the criticism of the culture industry in the next chapter
also a nice chapter he
says  we are also
being brought more and more into
a universal
blinding context by the entire culture industry example is
now can only bring a few examples
the film industry looks suspiciously the film
people calm down at
every manuscript that is not based on a
bestseller because
in capitalism it is obvious in the cinema
has to calculate and the box office has to
ring the fourth fees are also
calculated after the new
success is again
only produce films that
feel mass taste correspond to films that
are suitable for the masses and scripts that are just a bit
ironed against the grain have
no chance and that’s why  but do
we only see such films and
are more and more brought into line until it
's cheeky even if we
say yes well that's how we are
trimmed to mass taste and the second
problem he says is that it's becoming more and
more important we're always  more
fun quoted first of all catch well
english joy fun when is a
steel bath
that's already so close he says
the entertainment industry decrees it
incessantly laughing becomes an instrument
of cheating on happiness so because he says
we are artificially kept in a good mood
by comedy formats where  make some
fun and still make you laugh
though  that's a steel bath vienna who where
the soldiers were under artillery
fire we're being bombarded with comedy today
and it would ultimately be
a betrayal of our happiness we
have to laugh for a moment but it
's only done so that we don't
realize how unhappy we are  actually
are and are actually increasing comedy
formats there is a bearish study
content america also in
europe we are having more and more fun
and we would say laughing is
becoming an instrument of cheating on happiness the
big question is but why do we expose
ourselves to that  he says
adamantly you insist on the
ideology by which you get them
why
because people tune in every day
every night
and there is an answer you adamantly
insist on the ideology by which
you are enslaved and
you can't get out the people
complain  although always that the
program is so bad but they
turn on again and he himself has
si  ch then answered the question
why this is forbidden
probably for every citizen of the
wrong world a real one
would be unbearable he would be too damaged for himself
because of course bitter yes he says we
are basically already so damaged that
we can no longer create the real world
would and also whole
sentences the icing on the cake so we are
the reification by
capitalism we are losing the
ability to love we are brought into line by the
consumer industry we
are one-dimensional people without
individuality the ctt and
now language gives us the
rest language  is an organon of
domination because capitalism has
meanwhile managed to
penetrate the language games to form the language games
and we all have to speak
but we are completely captured through the language
language
is ultimately an organ of
capitalist domination that’s why he
can say beg  Reefs are ideal
tools for confronting nature and
how to master it, so it's
more like thinking I didn't
underestimate him, says our duo, because
language isn't that easy, only if you see
the origin of language then you
can say it's good  the first people there made
these are forest like that about who they
said it's an owl or air
india moved slowly they said
it's a sloth but these simple
terms they quickly become complex
and the idea is coming now he says he
the term is not just somehow created,
it is an ideal tool for
confronting nature and how it
can be controlled better and there is
also an example of
the slug the slug is
a vermin yes now he says this
term vermin something is being done there
the slug is asked by sin
to control it better because what
do you do with the pest you
produce a
pest control  and turns
it off and that says he is
exercising dominance as well as weeds because
look take the slug
for the duck that lives on the slug
it is not a pest for the duck
is an absolute beneficial or even for
the biologist who cares  a continuous
food chain is possible is the snail a
beneficial that is only from our
subjective point of view the slug is
the pest also weeds also everything
that grows is divided into what we
fight with weed killer
or what we accept and
we decide about the terms
therefore can  he says
thinking about identity says what something falls under, of which
it is a specimen or representative, what
is it not me, is the
slug itself,
seen in and of itself, is not a pest, yes, but we
make them a pest, so we classify
everything under concepts and that is an
exercise of power  there is
already power in the words and that
goes into de  r politics is common
practice politics knows that it is important to
exercise control over concepts, that is
what they know, for example when
adenauer called kabinett
sat together with his team and they wanted
the rearmament and rearmament of
Germany, that’s how it was
the germans were really
war tired after two world wars nobody wanted an
army anymore and should have it was very
difficult and then they thought about
it did you say if you now
open a main ministry again or
a war ministry
people don’t want that and then you have that
called the ministry of defense and there
was even a suggestion
to speak to the ministry of peace so that people would
n't get the idea that this
could again be related to war you
understand that way you can work with concepts
very consciously and purposefully and
basically the more dangerous things
become, the more  more one tries to
shut down the terms and vice versa  rt
maybe the last small example of
the power in language because we always think well
language as a neutral
one talks to each
other alfred dregger cdu politician once
quite consciously after a lost federal election
even set up a linguistic group to get terms from the spd roman
into the cdu  party program,
among other things, the terms progress
and freedom and the next election campaign
stand has kohl against schmidt candidacy
freedom or socialism and freedom
walter kohl and socialism was helmut
schmidt and that was that they
pulled through as a campaign and got 48.5
percent because they dream
today the cdu and you have to think about it
the trick was to identify kohl, helmut
kohl with freedom
and helmut schmidt with backward
dogged determination in socialism and the spd has
traditionally always had freedom and
progress on their journeys suddenly the term
was occupied hence the sentence
from brega the most important in de  r politics
is key terms to occupy yes that
is power of the language that we
are still exposed to afterwards dorner
by the way the economic language is
changing especially nowadays there are
studies in a dramatic way
adopts the military language more and more
so in the past such a leading
accountant was called authorized signatory authorized signatory comes from
latin the concern has provision
the urge today
is the chief financial officer that is the financial
boss and he has the cartridges the company owner
is no longer the cartridges but
today that is the chief executive officer
that is the one who executes and
we always have these language games  more at
the recruiting office so there is
recruiting there in some companies
there are even those who were given away sending
christmas presents and then a week
later the roster
says maneuver criticism christmas because then it
is about whether that has an effect
on the customers so that they see each other
language is power  and now we come
to the conclusion now says adorno
overall it looks
like we are getting into this total delusion context through the entirety of these
capitalist systems,
so his thesis is the whole
thing that is untrue now we
are asking ourselves two
essential questions yes where from  does he
then want to have it even if he himself is
also part of the objective blindness
together how does he even know
that we are manipulated if he says
there is no right life in the wrong one
then he is right in the middle of it how
we know that and that's mine  adorno would
n't be there then he wouldn't have an
answer again he says the embodied moment
tells the realization that the suffering
doesn't exist that it should be different
the embodied moment doesn't tell us the
suffering so we suffer from it, so
to speak, even if we're completely
manipulated, for example  they
are looking for an apartment in munich
and they are perfect  we all know it's expensive
and then you think well well at
school we learned free play
of forces
prosperity democracy and that's part of the
free market economy of course when a
product becomes scarce then the price goes up
so the landlord gets a lot of money in the
grocery store they sell them
groceries so that you can
still find customers and not on a
whim they do it cheaper
but the way you find customers
and the landlord sounded and even if
you are completely manipulated and see
everything and clearly hang him I have
to be like that  that's how we learned
suffers closely and the suffering tells us
that something shouldn't be like that, even an
employee who really gets involved who
really plays along in the
competitive thing and does everything
if he burns out it can be
that he's completely ideological
runs compliant and still goes to work where she is
already dirty but at some
point the suffering will show up again  he says
that things should be different the second
big question we have to ask adorno
now is okay assuming we
are here in the manipulated world we
feel through our suffering that we have to
change something but how do we get
out how do we get out
at all  out because he says yes
more radically than plato there is no
right life in the wrong one
the ideology does not overlay the
social existence as a detachable
layer
but he always has the
ideology that holds everything together this
not only on top as a detachable
layer that we make criticism in geology
and  free us from that but
the ideology that is inherent in society
that is already in all of us and
that's why he says we can't
get out of it and of
course he was also heavily
criticized by the Marxists, among others
georg lukac
lukac then said yes, adorno der
makes it easy because he says clearly you
can't do anything we live in the
o  bjective blinding context and
adorno i would quote this time off the
head but i think it is really
worth it retreats and that is absolutely
literally into the grand hotel abyss
one retreats into the hotel abyss
and after once in this gran
hotel he has  the luxury of no longer having to get
involved because there is nothing you can
do yes there is the greatest
cultural pessimist she has ever existed and
there is of course a bit of truth
to the criticism and even when the
student revolts started in 1968
the students then wanted after them
you have to imagine for ten
years adorno had educated entire generations of
students to be system core
critical system cores who carefully
criticized the system and now
the unrest started in 1968 and everyone
thought adorno was at the forefront of
the demonstrations and was fighting nothing with the
politicians  adorno
wanted to write his aesthetic theory
there is quite n  nice anecdotes at the
beginning of the riots he walks through the
hall the students have already
everything is occupied again and everyone can see
erdogan is coming the word is getting around everyone is
looking yes goes to the lectern everyone is
looking forward to applause breaks out
what's up he turns right  and goes to the
philosophical seminar as soon as they understand each other
and then he also
got scared that everything would change and
he then even occupied the students
of the institute for social research
then with his
consent the police cleared the campus
is picture there he is  next to the policemen in the
club what the students then photo
copied and distributed there is a
disgrace they were bitterly
disappointed in him and he then
also writes to markus i markus ii in turn
they were always there who demonstrated with them
at the front line
thought it was time for
revolutionary change, then he wrote
to marcuse about the danger of the envelope  i
take the student movement in fascism a
lot harder than you do you
just look into the manically frozen eyes of
those who possibly
turn their anger against us by referring to us
so he
thought dialectically again when he was ten years
old and  now the
anger maybe lines itself and that was
all bad for him well and
then it was a totally scary one and
then it came to the famous bosom assassination
there he was just standing at the lectern again
and then there were no student
actions three students are barefoot
shirtless ran in front of them  threw
flower petals and tried
to kiss him and adorno then
tried
to keep these naked women away with his briefcase then
found the briefcase ran to the room house
yes was totally frustrated and
his lectures were then also blown up
and then he wanted to stand at the
blackboard  do something or do you want to
keep acting forever yes and the word
abon  kidneys was then throughout the
student body term for
but finally to all the altar
trained yes and not closed but you do
madonna and of course wrong if
we just see that now and
lukas is not quite right either because there
is undoubtedly something great about donna  recognized
this dialectic of enlightenment
there is no doubt there is
adorf by the way very much in the tradition of
nietzsche has already said the
enlightenment has led to god being
dead god is dead and now a
vacuum has emerged after god is dead
there is  neither religious nor
metaphysical world guaranteeing
identity anchors me and in this
vacuum he says never comes now
false idolatry people
worship materialistic philosophies
like socialism capitalism etc
anti-semitism all sorts of things
to still somehow
feel alive and donner now says this
vacuum  was filled by the
natural sciences  the only ones who are still
familiar are the gods in white and
that is a great danger that the
dialectic will then change and
new myths will arise about natural science,
so to speak, yes
and an
example of this is actually
these races were darwin
wanted that of course maybe not
there  only a few passages that are a
bit critical but it was laid out in
that direction and
then this act of
annihilation took place which was complete madness
all the more so we have to always
distrust
natural science in particular the egoistic
gene of this book by this famous
geneticist dawkins in america was something  it used to be a
bestseller when you read that
then you go to the supermarket what's the
gain with it yes and since we
also say the adorno that's new
mysticism again where we have to be careful and
he also gave us something at the end
like we did  should live in the wrong
state today he says
on the one hand
we have to remain critical and to do this
dialectics in 1 imprint of the
universal blinding context
and its criticism in a final
movement against itself
like saying what we are of course if we
now organize the world and say so and
so the world says it  we have to be
clear about the fact that we only
formulate the theses that maybe and
ideologically have been said since childhood
and we have to criticize that
and even our criticism that we then
practiced about the
delusion context we have to criticize again in the last
movement  so
it's basically the negation of the
negation is is a hard self-
criticism an insight critique that we have to
do in order to see something beyond the context of the combustion
he's also been writing since the author he's been talking about
it in the third person quite
majestically he's been writing since  the author
trusted his own impulses, he
felt it was his task  with the
power of the object to break through the wear of constitutive
subjectivity so
every object so he too since who
has trusted his own thinking of
course subjectively individually tries to
imagine the world at the same time
says but what did one of his
tasks feel this illusion
what he himself of  the world had to break through again with the
same individually constitutive
power here too there
is this self-criticism in it again
the next hint he gives us how
we should live in the wrong state is a
bit more practical not so abstract because he
says you should go as far
as possible  live as one
believes one should live in a liberated world
with all the unavoidable
contradictions and conflicts that
this entails try to
anticipate the form of existence
that would actually be the right one, i.e. that
we should live as if we want to
live as if what we as  utopia
maybe have in mind sc  hon
reality would i give an example
i have a girlfriend she is a
radical vegan yes she is also the
calculator and also politically active and
stands up for the rights of animals and she
does it as if it had
already been realized and we would
already
living in this animal-free world, so to speak, where
the dignity of the animals and is accepted
and the animals have rights that
is not only expressed by the fact that she is not
an animal and also does not wear a leather belt
or animal skin, but she
then also lives by being  for example
on the internet then hunters or butchers
meat are also dubbed as murderers
although from our
criminal law no murderers apply under criminal law yes but she
acts as if we were already there and
takes the point of view that robin hood also
stuck to what adorno
says he has in the  basically, although there were still
nobles and an unequal distribution
, he already lived as if there
was a legal reason for that  the
goods are redistributed yes and of course there will
be problems of course the
robin hood would also be persecuted that's why
he says that this leads to accidents
and conflicts
but we have to endure these contradictions and conflicts and here he
says for example  the only thing one can
perhaps say is that the
right life today would be in the form of
resistance to transparent forms
of the wrong life you see
how carefully worded when he says
it is difficult to get out but the
utopia the only thing one can say
is that  we can just go into the resistance
against already seen through with
wrong life here it becomes
even clearer now the utopia lies
essentially in the definite
negation of what is going on and
that through the fact that it
concretizes as something wrong, what should be can always be indicated at the same time
the sentence
now sounds more difficult but it is quite
simply the diale  ktiker knows what
specific negation is the
key term specific negation so
if we say we are
criticizing something then we are not criticizing
abstractly but rather something very
specific and concrete if you are against
nuclear power then it is a very
specific form of energy and you are in favor of
the abolition of this form of energy because
Since residues and waste will remain a burden for
future generations and if
we fight against nuclear power specifically now
then the
concrete specific negation of
nuclear power should already contain the utopia of a
state without nuclear power so the
negation already contains something to do he
can say the utopia  is in the
definite negation of it by concretizing
the negative as wrong
and thereby always at the same time
pointing out what should be where
we say yes we don’t even have to always
think in alternatives and say yes
then put up the defense with the
energy in front of me  says no alone in de  m
we specifically oppose nuclear power
if it is abolished,
that automatically means that we
then have to look after other
energies, such as gas and coal, wind turbines, so
that yes, and then you can go back to
negations and say, well, they
too  Coal-fired power plants are not that great,
so we constantly have to go into new
indications and if it is a
specific, concrete negation of something
, we can go well beyond that
and come to the very end if
I tell you again, then the
negative dialectic makes a nice one here
defines once again what
his philosophy actually is,
what is critical theory and he says
it is about the draft of a
philosophy that does not presuppose the concept of the
identity of being and thinking
and does not terminate in it,
but that articulates exactly the
opposite, i.e. its integrity
so normally we were brought up
thinking about identity
and
in  personal area i too
one has to first have a personal identity
and identity crises and when we are in the
clear with our self-image
identity means nothing more
than oneself equality is actually
an interesting concept that can
be applied to people at all
because who is with
transferred to humans it would
mean that we are completely at
peace with ourselves so the image we have of
ourselves things because we want to be
holds and then we really hold and then are will
have us in the clear
which we know we  are real as soon as
we aren't but we have an
identity crisis or we want to be two
meters tall but are only 170
then we have an identity crisis because we do
n't agree with the image of what we wanted of ourselves
with the ideal i
can also be the others  tell us
that it's not what we think it is
that we are ready that we have an
identity crisis  e and he still says
yes it is like that but it has to be like that there is
nothing worse than when a person
is satisfied with themselves and is at peace with themselves
the identity
we must not end in the identity so we must not end in the identity
we have to develop further and criticize ourselves precisely when we are at peace
with ourselves
the identity is bad it is
also bad in the overall political framework
the identity
of thinking and being e.g. with hegel you
know with hegel there is this
world spirit and  the individual and
we are constantly evolving and
on the higher levels the following happens with
hegel, we are
no longer alien to humanity and others
as individuals but
there is total reconciliation so in
the future we know ourselves as a species
and the species  whitish as the sum of the
individuals we merge with the
whole nothing comes to total
reconciliation even goes like this  far that
existence at some point knows itself as all
matter, so as we also know
that we ultimately started in evolution from
amino acids, the process
we also exist as matter and are
an end product of matter, but when
it goes against this, being and
thinking together  and similarly with
marx with max it is also like that there
is at the end of a classless
society where all the contradictions come
to rest there is more
slave owners of the society before ideal
society bourgeois society
socialist communist
society and than at the beginning the
classless society with the  old
germans and so and then in the end
we come back to the classless
society and then the contradiction calms down
and others say no that's wrong there
is nothing worse than when
dialectic calms down there is nothing
worse than this unity for
example a kingdom a people  a will
a leader can the state  don't be
we always have to be critical that's why he
can say it's in the definition of
negative dialectics that you don't
know i calm down
and
and no matter how much he was the greatest
cultural pessimist that
maybe ever
existed he still said something to us i think
to go into negation of this permanent criticism without going into positions
it is not pointless even
if we don't get out
of it afterwards from the objective
delusion context something
of our criticism is not pointless saying he stays
alive remains and with the last
quote I would like to  let the last
word he says what was once thought
can be suppressed forgotten
pass by but
there is no excuse that some of
it remains in that sense
stay critical thank you
[applause]